and what's the next award Goldie the
next award is for film editing and such
an important one
editing is one of the most sensitive
indispensable parts of the business
really joy oh absolutely Goldie it
implies the assemblage of the creative
outpourings of the writer the nuances
and effluence of the director the deeply
subjective gifts of the actors the
instincts of the producer the magic of
the cinematographer it determines the
shape the form the thrust and the rhythm
of a motion picture
that's what editing means to me what
does it mean to you golden it means some
guy slaps two pieces of film together
and Warren Beatty gets all the close-ups
you know what we're doing don't you
we're plugging the hell out of shampoo
and we can't even mention the Duchess to
do it to present the award for film
editing we have a very interesting hands
across the sea combination he was
memorable as a doctor in mash worked
with Ingmar Bergman in the touch
currently appears in I will I will for
now and has just been a shooting Harry
and Walter go to New York Elliott Gould
and along with him we warmly welcome to
the United States a star already famous
in Europe and a nominee for Best Actress
this year for her role in the story of
Adele H which I announced in awe she
played in two complete versions one in
English and one in French and I can do
no less so welcome Bienvenue miss
Mademoiselle Isabelle Adjani
I'm glad to be here
we are very happy to have you here ease
it up thank you
then for best achievement in film
editing the nominees are Dede Allen for
Dog Day Afternoon
well now fields for Jose Russell lie for
the man who would be king Richard -
Lindsay Klingman and chill and Kong for
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
Frederick Stine camp and Don guide us
for three days of the Condor and the
winner is
Indiana 86 68
we uh first I want to say that giving me
this I consider a great tribute to our
wonderful fabulous talented director
Steven Spielberg I would also have to
say that being here at this time for all
these years I really have a long list of
thank-yous which I won't bother you with
but I hope everybody on that list
primarily my two sons I say thank you